Looking at this term, the constant factors
are 5, 7, and 2. So, we can write
those in the first three slots right here.
Because of the commutativity of
multiplication it doesn't matter what
order we write the 5, 7, and 2
in. Instead, I could have written 2,
7, 5 or 2, 5, 7 or 7,
5, 2, or any order of these three
numbers in these first three slots. For
simplicity sake, I'm just going to leave
mine written this way, but you're answer
is right as long as these three constant
factors are in these first three slots.
Now, what's left over to deal with are the
variable factors. So for those, we have x,
y and z. Here, it's important to remember,
the invisible multiplication signs between
these constant factors in the adjacent
variables. Remembering that those are
there is what's going to allow us to pull
out the variables and move them around.
So, I'm just going to keep x, y, and z in
the order they're written in and fill them
into the slots right here. Now, just like
with the constant factors, we could write
these variables in any order that we want
to. We could write z,y,x, z,x,y, x,y,z,
actually, that's what we have, [LAUGH]
y,x,z, . Any order these three variables
go in is correct as long as they are in
these last three slots.